moins de 24 heures après le deuxième
débat de la primaire de la gauche est
déjà le retour sur le terrain
lundi 16 janvier arnaud montebourg a
fait le déplacement aux mureaux une
ville qu'il veut prendre pour exemple il
ya ici beaucoup de créativité
d'ingéniosité pour faire vivre tout le
monde ensemble et dans l'harmonie
commune et ça c'est un effort
considérable de toutes parts il y a
beaucoup d'éléments du projet que je
porte qui finalement permettrait de
changer beaucoup de la vie des gens des
quartiers populaires aux poules molière
l'ancien ministre a échangé avec
l'association tendre la main
elle a pu lui parler d'un système de
transport permettant aux détenus de voir
leurs proches plus facilement
aujourd'hui je lui ai exposé l'idée du
taxi parloir après voilà il a été très
très réceptifs à ce à cette action là
ils pensaient pas des actions de ce type
se faisait et voilà ça nous a permis
aussi de voilà de d'exposer cette action
et découvre la meinau selon un sondage
réalisé après le deuxième débat de la
primaire de la gauche 29 % des
téléspectateurs ont jugé arnaud
montebourg candidat le plus convaincant
de la soirée chez les sympathisants de
gauche benoît hamon arrive en tête
ils s'affronteront à nouveau avec
l'ensemble des candidats lors du dernier
débat ce jeudi 19 janvier